ah
[Música]
a
el gobierno peruano decretó el retorno a
la cuarentena durante la semana santa
con la finalidad de contener la
propagación del cob y 19 se ha dispuesto
que las actividades religiosas se
realicen de manera virtual y sean
transmitidas por el canal del estado y
las redes sociales los ciudadanos sólo
podrán salir a comprar productos de
primera necesidad a pie o en bicicleta
se prohíbe el uso de vehículos
particulares también queda prohibido el
transporte interprovincial aéreo como
terrestre los gremios de turismo afirman
que no fueron consultados por el
gobierno para imponer las medidas y esta
denuncia les está ocasionando cuantiosas
pérdidas todas las reservas de hoteles
que tenía fueron canceladas mientras
tanto en el rubro de los restaurantes
alertan que la cuarentena le generará
pérdidas del 40 por ciento en sus
ingresos el ánimo de la población se
divide en tres quienes quieren una
semana santa sin restricciones y lo que
desean pasarla encerrados y lejos del
coronavirus
[Música]
a punto de separar 300.000 muertos
brasil sigue sin un plan nacional para
luchar contra la pandemia cada uno de
los 27 estados tiene que hacer sus
propias reglas en río de janeiro acaban
de aprobar un lock down de 10 días entre
el 26 de marzo el 4 de abril sólo
funcionarán los servicios esenciales las
playas estarán cerradas así como las
tiendas los museos y los cines para
conseguirlo han anticipado los festivos
de todo un año para conseguir que la
población no tenga que salir a la calle
durante 10 días una medida parecida
también en san paolo la ciudad más
afectada del país y también la más
poblada y para evitar una desbandada de
paulistas hacia las playas del litoral
las ciudades de esta área también han
aplicado un lock down y prohíben el
alquiler de las casas de temporadas
mientras el presidente de persona no se
sigue oponiendo al lock down y la semana
pasada incluso fue al tribunal supremo
para denunciar las medidas de alcaldes y
gobernadores
[Música]
las cifras siguen siendo muy
preocupantes en chile- el gobierno toma
medidas restrictivas y una de las
últimas polémicas la protagoniza
exactamente la iglesia católica que
manifestó en un comunicado que
restringir las misas en la fase 2 es
decir aquellos lugares donde la
cuarentena se limita únicamente al fin
de semana es atentar contra la libertad
religiosa el gobierno reaccionó
rápidamente a la presión permitiendo las
misas con un aforo de hasta 20 personas
pensando en las necesidades espirituales
y también en la semana santa sin embargo
a partir de este jueves 14 de los 19
millones de chilenos estarán bajo un
encierro total lo que hace pensar que la
semana santa de este 2021 se parecerá
más a la de 2020 que a la de años
anteriores el sector de turismo se ve
golpeado manifiesta sus quejas y también
solicita ayudas económicas al gobierno
un gobierno que muestra sus
contradicciones como señalaron en una
carta esta misma semana los funcionarios
y el servicio nacional de turismo que
manifiestan su descontento al verse
forzados a tener que acudir
presencialmente a trabajar incluso en
los lugares donde están en cuarentena
para dar
[Música]